inside the mobile measurements
meteorologists dr. bruce lee and dr.
kathy Findlay drive toward the storms
periphery to take wind speed and
pressure measurements
[Music]
but as they get into position they're
blasted by winds from another storm that
develops out of nowhere
[Music]
the strong winds forcely and Finley's
into a dish confining them in their car
[Music]
receives word that the team is in grave
danger and must come to their aid when
speeds approach 110 miles per hour as
the tornado gets closer
[Music]
at this point Bruce and M got blown into
the ditch up there all right that's
clear if they can't quickly free them as
a net they may lose the chance to
measure the tornado suddenly another
massive tornado begins to develop just
over the horizon that whole thing is a
large tornado you can see it right in
there it's dangerously close to the team
tim has only minutes to free the car
[Music]
the Meza net is free but now the team is
between two tornadoes one moving away
from them one moving toward them all
right let's go let's go get it good job
all right the tornadic portion of the
storm is within about 29 29 miles okay